faucet like it was more like 2010 that
like women were being objectified but I
feel like it started earlier than I
thought well I was born in 96 I kind of
missed the whole 90s thing thank you I
was born in 1990 as well I love wu-tang
clan just what high schools supposed to
be like I hope so
you know I never really thought about
the naughty private school girls oh I
saw this video right I wish school was
just dance I know it's like a dirty High
School Musical I love this song because
it was long as we why is his hair white
oh my god oh and she's like there's no
problem this little girl just picked up
my underwear on team anaconda but but
anaconda but a little more like tamed
you're saying song a lot what are those
gloves lots of uh oh that was kind of
torquing sort of see what's funny and so
like in the 90s all their unemployed
painting suits was really scandalous
and now it's a double D job oh wow that
is next-level graphic yeah why is
everything blue that's why I want to
know I mean I just want to know what you
know gave him the inspiration maybe
there's lowest the special effects are
really bad whoever edited this must've
been like my life is over at this point
Oh Oh frosted tips guys he's gonna get
those are coming back I feel it alright
Missy Elliott the ring a lot about Missy
Elliott she's wearing like a black SATs
it kinda looks like a trash bag did
people think this is norm I'm still
amazed by her hair seriously like just
the weave you know that is a hat I don't
believe that this is a serious music
video like I feel like this is a parody
oh this song is so good she's like a
leopard in the desert her clothes look
like my bedspread I used to have that
when I was a kid I feel like this is it
like if you went out like this in the
90s like people just see like okay why
would she go off in the desert by
yourself song was really annoying yeah
actually it's like Taylor Swift but with
leopard print yeah I would say 90s
videos or oh no what much more abstract
then
yeah cuz now it's like oh let's stick a
button
mom